Speaker 1: All right, it's Friday,
let's get into this week's mailbag,
remember, you can email info at David Pakman
dot com with your thoughts, your questions,
your anything really just know. Try to reduce the
abuse in the email. And don't send 10 10 emails a
day. You'll get yourself flagged directly into the
trash. And we've sadly, there's like 50 people now
getting auto filtered directly into the trash.
OK, let's start. Today's first email is actually
not an email. It's from Twitter, where a user
named Ackbar said David, who does your vetting
for your calls. It seems like a large portion
is just trolling you and getting you to answer
questions that are asked in bad faith pretending
to be progressive. You know, there are a lot of
really fair critiques of our phone callers,
including that they take five minutes to get
to the question that they call from really loud
places that they don't really have anything to ask
but just kind of want to rant for a while. There's
a lot of really good critiques. I don't think
this critique is accurate, that people are
trolling me and asking bad faith questions. I
have never gotten that impression and that they're
pretending to be progressive. If anybody can even
point to one specific such call, I, if this is
happening, it's going completely over my head
and I should be aware of it. So please let
me know if there are specific calls that that
meet that definition because I haven't seen
them. Here's another message via Facebook.
You are a habitual liar. Now, you know, you can
say, Hey, David, sometimes you get things wrong.
You can say David. Sometimes when it's statistics
or math or calculus related elements on the show,
you get them wrong or sometimes you get a fact
wrong. But one of the things I don't do here
is lie to you or tell you that I believe things
that I don't really believe everything I say on
the program. I really believe and I believe, to
be true at the time. And sometimes I get things
wrong, and when I am aware of it, I will
apologize. I throw myself at the mercy of
the audience and I issue a correction. I will.
I will do that a few emails from now because I
was corrected about something. But this is
not a program where I lie to the audience
or pretend to have beliefs that I don't either,
because I think it will be more interesting or
generate more clicks or views or whatever the case
may be. I don't do that. There are shows that do
it, and I won't name them partially because I
don't watch them. But, but there are shows I'm
sure that do that, but this is not one of them.
All right. OK, Joe wrote in. Joe says, Hey David,
I was scrolling through Facebook when I noticed
one of my anti-vax Facebook friends who's a nurse,
shared the below post from
Halifax Health in Florida.
I can't wrap my head around why a hospital
would share this. How do we fight this nonsense?
This is food to anti-vax Republicans. Can you
look into it? So what Joe is referring to is that
Halifax Health shared something showing that a
lot of the people in the hospital were vaccinated
with COVID, that there were a bunch of vaccinated
people in the hospital. And as I've said before,
one of the things we must understand is that as
more and more people are vaccinated, the odds
by sheer base rates that more of the hospitalized
are vaccinated goes up. What we have to understand
is your relative risk. As I said before, the
thought experiment is in a country where you have
100 percent vaccination. Anyone who's hospitalized
will be vaccinated. Does that mean the vaccines
don't reduce the risk of hospitalization? Of
course not. And as we've seen many times before,
you know, I'm making up numbers here. Imagine you
have 70 percent vaccination and 40 percent of the
hospitalized are vaccinated. Well, that's
a much larger share of the population, and
they are relatively a much smaller portion of the
hospitalized than as we've seen before. The risk
reduction for hospitalization or death from COVID
is significant. I don't even remember the latest
numbers at this point because we continue to get
more and more precise numbers. But you have to
understand the relative risk and Joe is not wrong.
It is food or fodder for anti-vax Republicans
because they don't understand the meaning of the
numbers. If they understood math and base rates,
then it would not be anti-vax fodder.
Unfortunately, they don't. And therefore,
it is OK, Steve wrote to me. Here's an interesting
perspective from Steve or Stephen. Trump's
vaccine advocacy is an indicator he doesn't
intend to run into. 24. Steve writes, David,
knowing that everything Trump does is to benefit
himself. Why is he now promoting the vaccine,
knowing it will cost him potential voters? Perhaps
he's more concerned about his legacy. Might this
be an indicator that he does not intend to
run in 2024 at this point? I have no idea.
This is one argument that can be made. Trump is
now going fully for vaccines because he doesn't
care about the repercussions. The problem is he's
not really going fully. He's still talking about
you should have your freedoms, and I'm not sure
about vaccinating kids and all these different
things. So I reject that he's really going that
much pro vaccine. But the counterpoint that some
people have wrote to me have written to me and
said, some people who wrote to me said, Is that
what Trump is doing is getting ahead of the fact
that it does seem plausible that in the next year,
COVID will be dramatically reduced. It'll go
into an endemic phase, and he wants to make sure
that as that happens, people think of him and the
vaccines so so you can pick any interpretation you
want. I don't know that we're really going to know
what Trump's thinking is at this point in time,
Eric wrote. Oh, actually, Eric's making this
exact point. By the way, this is not the crazy,
anti-vax Eric in mass. This is a different Eric
and mouse. He says, Hey, David, do you think
Trump's recent endorsement of the vaccine is being
caused by some health officials forecasting that
the COVID pandemic is hopefully winding down?
Maybe he's realizing there will be something to
take credit for soon. So rather than belittling
it, he's better off taking credit for it. Thanks.
This is exactly what I was just suggesting
that some people were writing to me about
must have been in my head because we had this
email here. That's another interpretation of
Trump now saying the vaccines are good,
the vaccines are safe and I made them.
This is just as plausible an explanation. OK, Mr.
H wrote to me. About Dr. Anthony Fauci. And says
greetings. Is it possible that Dr. Fauci may need
to seek political asylum if the Republicans gain
full control of the government regards? I am not
willing to accept that Dr. Fauci would need to
leave the country for safety. If Republicans take
over in November now, a lot of really bad things
are likely to happen if Republicans take over in
November. There was no question about that. But
particularly because he has armed security, which
is insane that Dr. Fauci needs it. But he does.
I believe that Dr. Fauci will be able to safely
stay in the United States, even if Republicans
gain full control of the government in 2024
or control of the House and or Senate in 2022.
If you have a different perspective on Dr.
Fauci, safety by all means, let me know.
Olav wrote in about a mathematical error, which
I always want to correct. He says, David, sir,
in your January 12th show, you claimed one
percent and four point five percent were
imaginary numbers. When talking about our Macron
giving fewer hospitalizations in mathematics,
imaginary numbers are well defined. Its real
numbers multiplied by an imaginary unit. I
I is defined as if you square it, it equals minus
one I would rather use made up numbers instead of
imaginary. This is a completely fair critique.
I said the other day, these are imaginary
numbers and it really was not precise. What
I meant was I'm making these numbers up.
Imaginary numbers have a precisely defined
meaning in math, and I apologize if I confused
anybody with that. Ruth wrote in. And Ruth
says the future of the United States scares me.
Ruth says, Hi, David. I've been listening to your
show for about a year. I really appreciate your
reporting on current events. After listening to
yourself and others, I'm very concerned about
the future of the US. Me too. Lately, I have been
considering moving out of the U.S. I was wondering
if you've ever thought about this yourself or
if you think the U.S. will turn around. Yeah,
I mean, listen, I am. I always have. You know,
we learn more and more about kind of peoples.
There's this return to the mean thing where
we learn that people seem to have different
levels of kind of natural optimism, satisfaction
and happiness, and individual events will push
and pull us one way or the other. But that
most people, unless they work really hard,
have kind of a natural mean or status quo. And my
status quo is kind of like cautious optimism, but
let's make sure we have a backup plan in place.
So as many of you know, I was born in Argentina,
I could move back to Argentina anytime. That's
one backup now for the last many decades.
It's not been an appealing thing because things
have been worse in Argentina, that in the U.S.
in many, many different ways. So that's one
backup. Number two is I could move to Israel
and obtain citizenship there. So that's a
backup. And the third backup that I'm waiting on
or working on right now is there. I have many of
you might know I have family roots in Poland. My
family from Poland on my maternal grandfather
side fled Poland because of the Holocaust fled
to Argentina. There is a provision where if you
can prove your lineage and that your family left
under those circumstances, you can get a
Polish passport, which would give me you
access full EU access. I am working on that.
It's really difficult because by its nature,
the records that prove that lineage from Poland
are potentially nonexistent because they were
burned up in the Holocaust. The part of Poland
that my family is from is now part of Belarus.
As many of you know, the political situation in
Belarus is complex. There are not exactly good
working relationships between Belarus and Poland.
So if anybody here is in Belarus and might be able
to help me get the documents, I need get in touch.
But that's my third backup that I'm working on and
I have not seriously considered permanently
leaving the U.S., but certainly I am worried
enough about the future of the U.S. that I want to
have a plan in place. So it's a long answer, Ruth,
but I hope I've answered it to your satisfaction.
Email info at David Pakman dot com. If you have
anything that you want to see in the mailbag, we
have a fantastic bonus show for you today. You can
sign up at join Packman dot com use the coupon
code wwr twenty two to get a discount and we'll
see you either on the bonus show today or back on
Unidentified: the Monday program.